[Music]
there's plenty of Game of Thrones trivia
to be found online
I showed this epic is sure to have its
behind the scene surprises and easter
eggs galore but diehard fans are
probably sick of hearing the same old
bit so rejoice super nerds here are a
few nuggets out of Westeros even the
show's biggest fans may not have heard
yet oh my god well you have your very
own Game of Thrones iron throne toilet
ok maybe that guy knows all this but do
you watch the throne in the books the
iron throne itself is epic
it's made of a thousand swords and has
actual stairs you have to climb to reach
the seat the show's producers decided to
go with something more realistic but the
show's prop throne does hide some pretty
epic Easter eggs for the super fan when
you play the game of Thrones you win or
you die as some obsessed
redditors first pointed out and IGN
reported if you look closely at the
throne you should spot a copy of Gandalf
sword from Lord of the Rings as well as
swords from Robin Hood Prince of Thieves
and kingdom of heaven heart of gross in
one of the most memorable scenes from
season 1
Daenerys chair down on a stallion heart
to win the approval of the Dothraki
bigwigs actress Emilia Clarke wasn't
faking her disgust the horse heart she
was eating was actually made of a gummy
bear like substance that had been
injected with a red sugary syrup so
blood would realistically burst out at
the heart and slow down her face so she
ate but just because something is sweet
doesn't mean it's palatable Clarke says
she spent much of the day heaving into a
bucket King confusion on the show the
night King is the imposing leader of the
White Walkers in the books there is a
character named the night's king but he
is a legendarily cruel human figure not
a white Walker 13 years he and his queen
ruled over
brothers making sacrifices as black of
that clock in the books these
freezer-burnt freaks in fact do not
appear to have any noticeable social
structure or hierarchy at all let alone
a king making his icy highness
a TV exclusive slice and dice game of
thrones' television sensation around the
world but we're not all necessarily
watching the same thing when China's
state TV stations began rearing for
series in 2014
fans quickly noticed that they had
heavily censored the episodes
cutting nearly all of the violence and
nudity that's a bit like cutting all of
the roadrunner chasing out of the wily
coyote cartoon but it could be worse
in Turkey the government outright banned
the show in 2014 from being played at
the country's military training schools
citing a desire to protect recruits from
viewing images of sexual exploitation
pornography exhibitionism abuse
harassment and all negative behaviors
wandering minstrels
quite a few musicians have made cameos
on the show through the years including
snow patrol singer Gary Lightbody making
a vocal contribution Hixton world amid
so fair but he looked the honey air from
her her Coldplay drummer will champion
doing his thing at the infamous red
wedding and Icelandic post rock group
Segura Ross playing minstrels at
Joffrey's wedding
hey good very good off you go three
members of the metal group Mastodon also
made an appearance during the battle at
hardhome and frontman Brent Hinds is set
to make a reappearance in season seven
in the same role singer-songwriter ed
Sheeran will also make his season 7
cameo orchestrated as a surprise for his
fan Maisie Williams also known as Arya
Stark stunts but many Jon Snow fans may
have swooned when they got a glimpse of
a spare bottom during the season 3 cave
scene with Ygritte unfortunately that
wasn't the real deal shortly before
filming for the season began actor Kit
Harington says he fell from a
second-story window ledge in a drunk of
attempts to retrieve his keys from his
lock flaps breaking an ankle which left
him unable to film full body shots for
the first few weeks luckily a similarly
built crew members stepped in to lend a
but siren a night we were but this old
scope that you're making even
comfortable thanks for watching click
the looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know you love to
[Music]